bonjour à tous et bienvenue cette vidéo
est sponsorisé par le jeu vidéo dix
architectes paris développé par le
studio français et nodo ce jeu vous
permet de modifier les quartiers de la
ville de paris au gré de vos envies la
ville a été reproduite en 3d par deux
architectes qui sont à l'origine de ce
projet alors contrairement à d'autres
jeux de construction de villes vous ne
partez pas de zéro mais de la ville que
vous connaissez il s'agit de l'adapter
de la transformer selon votre propre
vision écologique historique futuriste
et c'est en plus pour une fois ce sont
pas les villes à l'américaine qu'on vous
propose de construire avec des avenues
des gratte ciel mais vous aurez la
possibilité de re façonné complètement
les façades anciennes les immeubles
haussmanniens et tous les bâtiments
emblématiques de la capitale dix
architectes paris est maintenant
disponible dans ces rations complètes
sur steam alors n'hésitez pas si vous
aimez l'histoire et l'architecturé
c'est hyper réaliste est satisfaisant
nous on a adoré nous voilà dans le
quartier saint-michel à deux pas des
magasins des campeurs
le collège de france qu'au bâtiment
qu'il est là mais moi j'ai pour projet
si tu d'accord d'annexés
tout le territoire voisin aidé à grandir
donc ça c'est l'emprise de bâtiments des
scolarité aude françois robert voyons
voir
sévère c'est pas mal on n'a pas peur
bien sûr pas très open space non non
nous on est pour le cloisonnement et le
travail dans l'intimité silence voilà ce
que ça donne et bien
capture photo f 12
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous propose un format un
peu inédit plutôt que de faire découvrir
la vie et le travail de quelqu'un
d'assez peu connue chez nous comme on
l'a fait avec margaret mythe dans cette
vidéo eh ben on va faire exactement le
contraire moi je voudrais revenir sur
les chercheurs en sciences humaines que
vous connaissez forcément et expliquer
pourquoi ils sont incontournables parce
qu'en fait qu'on connaît tous
lévi-strauss mais personne n'est capable
d'expliquer ce qu'il a fait ce monsieur
en fait c'est un peu une vidéo en forme
de rappel mais vous allez voir que ça
fait pas de mal parce qu'elle force
d'entendre leur nom partout sans qu'on
aurait expliqué jamais leur travail ben
on finit par ne plus vraiment savoir ce
qu'on leur doit on va donc essayer de
synthétiser l'apport réel de 4 penseurs
incontournable dans leur champ de
recherche sociologie anthropologie
archéologie et histoire
autrement dit les sciences humaines et
sociales shs
alors j'ai bien conscience que c'est un
exercice pratiquement impossible de
résumer en quelques minutes des villes
entières de travail d'autant plus
lorsqu'il s'agit des plus brillants
universitaires comptent emploi cette
vidéo n'a absolument pas la prétention
de faire une synthèse complète de leurs
oeuvres mais plutôt de mettre en
évidence les points les plus marquants
de leur travaux de vous donner des
pistes pour approfondir question est ce
qu'un live lecture de passages choisis
sur instagram pour prolonger la vidéo
vous intéresse dites moi ça en
commentaire
[Musique]
émile dürckheim aînés en 1858 à epinal
dans les vosges dans sa famille on est
rabbin de père en fils depuis des
générations mais émile va déroger à la
règle après une classe préparatoire au
lycée louis le grand et l'école normale
supérieure dürckheim et est agrégé de
philosophie la voie royale de
l'intellectuel français mais dürckheim
s'écarte de la philosophie il choisi de
rédiger une thèse de sociologie soit la
division du travail il considère en
effet que la philosophie est trop
éloignée des problématiques de son temps
plutôt que de philosopher sur des
notions abstraites
il veut participer au progrès social
grâce à la science cet héritage du vient
tout droit de la pensée d'auguste
comptes qui a d'ailleurs inventé le
terme de sociologie york times donne à
bordeaux à partir de 1887 les premiers
cours triologie dans une université
française il fonde aussi la revue
l'année sociologique en 1898 qui
cristallise autour d'elle de nombreux
jeunes chercheurs notamment grâce à son
neveu marcel mauss l'un des plus grands
noms de l'ethnologie française
à partir de 1902 dürckheim enseigne la
sociologie à paris à la sorbonne et
poursuit son effort pour ancrer cette
nouvelle discipline
l'institutionnaliser en homme pressé il
veut mettre rapidement la science au
service du progrès social et pour faire
cela il donne à la sociologie un objet
d'étude les faits sociaux dürckheim
définit un fait social comme un fait
réel qui existent en dehors des
individus il dit en 1895 dans les règles
de la méthode sociologique que les faits
sociaux sont des choses une formule choc
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre en
disant cela dure qui m'explique qu'on
peut les appréhender l'extérieur qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'être dans la tête des
gens pour comprendre la société il
distingue donc la sociologie de la
psychologie il étudie notamment le
suicide délai ces aspects psychologiques
ou philosophiques et montre statistiques
à l'appui que des facteurs sociaux
peuvent expliquer le phénomène si on se
suicide plus chez les ruraux que chez
les urbains ou chez les protestants que
chez les catholiques c'est que des
phénomènes sociaux entrent en jeu et
pour mettre en lumière les influences de
la société dürckheim utilise la méthode
comparative qui est l'équivalent pour la
science sociale de ce qu'est
l'expérimentation dans les sciences de
la nature en lui fournissant un objet
est une démarche propre dürckheim fait
de la sociologie une discipline à part
entière le titre de pertes sociologie
qu'on lui décerne souvent n'est donc pas
usurpée d'autant que son apport ne
s'arrête pas là dans sa thèse de la
division du travail social publié en
1893 il avait déjà théorisé une grande
séparation entre les sociétés humaines
celles qui possèdent une solidarité
mécanique les plus primitives et celle
où la solidarité est organique les
nôtres le passage de l'une à l'autre
découle selon lui de la division du
travail dans nos sociétés chacun exécute
une tâche spécialisés à la manière d'un
organe et dépend des autres ce qui
renforcerait la solidarité son travail
sur la religion est aussi
particulièrement fécond dans les formes
élémentaires de la vie religieuse en
1912 dürckheim aborde la religion comme
un phénomène avant tout sociale il
analyse le phénomène religieux à partir
des notions de sacré et de profane une
distinction qui est toujours au coeur de
son étude aujourd'hui mais mille
dürckheim s'éteint en 1917 à seulement
59 ans une partie de ses disciples est
décimée dans les tranchées de la grande
guerre et la sociologie française en est
durablement affecté au xxème siècle sa
sociologie tourné vers la recherche de
l'ordre et son rejet de la lune des
classes lui ont valu d'être considéré
comme un bourgeois conservateurs
pourtant l'oeuvre de turckheim porte
bien un projet de réforme de la société
seulement elle est graduelle et réseau
n'est pas révolutionnaire un peu à la
manière de jaurès dont il était proche
quoi qu'il en soit l' influence de la
pensée de turckheim est considérable en
sciences humaines lorsque
l'anthropologie a voulu se débarrasser
des théories biologique évolutionniste
elle a trouvé dans les faits sociaux
turckheim une opportunité de se
transformer
claude lévi strauss est né à bruxelles
en 1908 et grandi à paris où il fait une
classe préparatoire et passe
l'agrégation de philosophie super
original son mariage en 1932 avec
l'ethnologue guina dreyfus l'initient à
l'anthropologie en 1935 il est invité à
enseigner la sociologie à l'université
de sao paulo est le profil de ces années
brésilienne pour se rendre chez
plusieurs peuples amérindiens qui a
doublé aux bords aux toupies c'est une
envie cora interdite d'enseignement par
les lois antisémites de vichy il
embarque pour les états unis en 1941 à
new york où il a trouvé un poste
d'enseignant il rencontre parmi les plus
brillants esprits de l'époque il fait la
connaissance notamment de franz boas ce
qu'on a évoqué dans la vidéo sur
margaret mid et aussi de romane jacob
sont qui lui fait découvrir la
linguistique structurale qu'il inspire
énormément de retour en france à la fin
de la guerre il soutient sa thèse
d'anthropologie publié en 49 sous le nom
de structures élémentaires de la parenté
c'est une oeuvre nageurs donc vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler dans ce
texte il explore une intuition qu'il a
eu à savoir que l'interdît de l'inceste
est présent dans toutes les sociétés
humaines etc ils les forcent à échanger
avec autrui c'est pour lui ce qui sépare
nature et culture ce travail s'intéresse
en détail au système des changes de
femmes il étudie les règles qui oblige
dans certaines sociétés un homme à
épouser une femme en particulier
lévi-strauss met ainsi en évidence une
logique sous jacente des structures
général et cette méthode est popularisée
sous le nom de structuralisme le
structuralisme c'est en fait plus une
méthode d'analysé qu'une doctrine c'est
chercher les opérations penser qu'ils
créaient les faits sociaux en
distinguant quelques opérations
opposition analogie contraste et
quelques éléments de base on doit
pouvoir aboutir à toutes les formes
d'organisation sociale connus on peut
ainsi selon lévi-strauss révélé des
invariants et accéder à la nature
profonde de l'esprit humain c'est ce
qu'il va poursuivre toute sa vie durant
dans les années qui suivent de nombreux
autres ethnologue se lance dans une
étude similaire des systèmes de mariage
dans toutes les sociétés du monde en
1955 par être tristes tropiques son
ouvrage le plus littéraire et le moins
théorique et qui lui assure un succès
mondial récit me autobiographique me
sociologique il est traduit en 26
langues et reste un classique absolu de
la littérature en 1958 il publie en
anthropologie structurale un recueil
d'articles où il applique sa méthode
structurale à de nombreux domaines
langage religion arts grâce à cela il
est élu en 59 au collège de france où il
inaugure une chaire d'anthropologie
sociale ce nouvel environnement de
travail dope sa productivité en 62
lévi-strauss publie le totémisme
aujourd'hui dans lequel il brise le
mythe d'une religion originelle
totémisme et surtout la pensée sauvage
alors je voudrais m'arrêter un peu sur
ce livre et pas uniquement parce qu'il a
inspiré le nom de la chaîne youtube mais
dans ce livre qui est parfois considéré
comme le plus marquant de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
lévi-strauss dynamite la notion de
peuple primitif à cette époque les
anthropologues avait encore du mal à
expliquer pourquoi les peuples qu'ils
étudient tenait des discours aussi
irrationnel affirmant par exemple être
les enfants des animaux de la forêt ou
expliquant le monde par des mythes qui
n'ont ni queue ni tête eh ben les listes
rose dans cet ouvrage assez ardue il
faut le lire démontre qu'il n'est
absolument pas de confusion mentale de
la part de ces peuples mais au contraire
des opérations intellectuelle d'analogie
et de contrastes de transformation
logique qui forme une structure
cohérente non mais vraiment ne lisez pas
la pensée sauvage à ventre est ce trop
pikine on ne fait pas ça chez vous non
mais ça m'en faire il est par là
d'ailleurs dès lors non parce que quitte
à avoir un fond avec une bibliothèque
autant assumer un peu autant vous sortir
deux trois trucs parce que sinon ça sert
à rien c'est pas que de la mise en scène
ça sert nous avons koala anthropologie
structurale la pensée sauvage donc ne
commencez pas par sa et la ville la voix
des masques tristes tropiques ou pas il
est derrière ça tenait marcel mauss
quand on parlait tout à l'heure essai
sur le don marcel mauss il est connu
pour ça vous voyez là dans la
simple show et c'est moins chaud que la
pensée sauvage cet ouvrage réfute donc
la hiérarchie entre les cultures et des
bistrots acquiert une notoriété
gigantesque la porte est phénoménal de
cette révélation en fait un
incontournable et chaque courant
philosophique narcisse existentialisme
etc doit désormais se positionner face
au structuralisme de claude lévi-strauss
de 64 à 71 il s'attelle à une autre
analyse structurale celle des mythes
amérindiens publié en quatre volumes est
plus de 2000 pages deux autres volumes
de ces mythologique viendront s'ajouter
en 85 et 91 encore une fois c'est un
travail absolument colossal qui consiste
à comparer des milliers de mythes pour
déterminer leurs liens et finalement
aboutir à une clé de lecture universelle
de tous les mythes une application
magistrale de la méthode structurale en
73 dans la voie des masques il applique
la même méthode avec l'art amérindien de
la côte nord ouest à 80 ans passés il
continue de travailler de s'intéresser à
tous les arts et les sciences de son
temps mathématiques informatique
psychologie littérature et rudy complet
et intellectuels français le plus
influent du siècle il meurt quelques
jours avant son 101e anniversaire le 30
octobre 2009
[Musique]
andré leroi-gourhan nous sert ici à
illustrer l'archéologie et vous allez le
voir son travail touche aussi à
l'anthropologie et c'est sans doute la
raison pour laquelle son oeuvre est
aussi pérenne né à paris en 1911 andré
leroi-gourhan est orphelin de père à 4
ans est élevé par ses grands parents
maternels alors pas très doué pour
l'école il la quitte à 14 ans et
commence à travailler pas de pré papa
danic de philo donc non mais comme quoi
c'est possible gens vont se demander ce
qu'est ce qu'on raconte la philo moi
j'ai du mal à définir cette discipline
c'est à dire que c'est intéressant et
c'est utile quand la philosophie fait
finalement de la sociologie
d'hagiographie de l'anthropologie
mais en soi fin j'ai pas dit moi mais on
en parlait que lucas l'autre fois on a
l'impression que on surestime beaucoup
l'apport de la philosophie et ont fait
une grosse place une grande place dans
les médias traditionnels au philosophe
bon
il ya peut-être d'autres chercheurs
donnent discipline à voilà à mettre en
valeur leroi gourhan collectionne des
objets du monde entier dès l'adolescence
en fréquentant les marchés aux puces de
paris il y énormément et se met à
fréquenter les écoles d'anthropologie et
de langues orientales c'est là qu'il
devient d'ailleurs elle bibliothécaire
et reprend des études après un diplôme
de russes un autre de chinois et une
licence de lettres il suit
l'enseignement de marcel mauss au musée
d'ethnographie du trocadéro
il est rapidement chargé d'organiser une
exposition sur les eskimos aujourd'hui
on inuits mal hypocondrie eskimos dont
il est devenu à force de lecture et de
collection un éminent spécialiste sa
première publication est la civilisation
du renne en 1936 leur grande encore que
25 ans mais ils dessinent déjà les
perspectives qu'ils vont le guider toute
sa vie durant en étudiant les techniques
y croiser époques et les lieux il
rapproche les chasseurs du paléolithique
européens et les éleveurs de sibérie
actuelle en partant de leur relation
commune avec les rênes lui prend en
compte toutes les données climat
comportement animal artisanat mythologie
et envisage les pubs de la préhistoire
comme des civilisations à part entière
la guerre ne freine pas son activité
leroi gourhan passent les années
d'occupation a travaillé d'arrache-pied
et sera aussi décoré pour son engagement
dans la résistance il publie entre 43 et
45 les deux tomes de sa première oeuvre
capitale évolution et technique ces deux
livres constitue une percée importante
dans l'étude de la technologie en
introduisant notamment le concept de
chaîne opératoire dont j'ai déjà parlé
dans une précédente vidéo est ici mais
si vous souvenez c'est la vidéo sur la
tomographie les rayons x tous à rassurer
ses amis qu elle avait carrément aimé
cette vidéo vraiment l'a fait je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle soit aussi
bien accueilli cafasso tendu
à la libération il soutient sa thèse est
nommé professeur d'ethnologie à la
faculté lyon pas mal pour un gars qui a
quitté l'école à 14 ans c'est à lyon que
leroi gourhan commença à pratiquer
l'archéologie de terrain il organise en
effet des chantiers archéologiques
destiné aux étudiants ces fouilles
préhistoriques ont pour objectif
d'appliquer la méthode des ethnologues à
l'archéologie est ainsi rapproché les
deux disciplines les vestiges matériels
s'ils sont bien étudiés révèle selon lui
les mentalités les structures sociales
même pour les sociétés préhistoriques
voilà son cheval de bataille et pour
faire cela il faut changer les
techniques de fouilles la méthodologie
qui met en place avec ses étudiants est
particulièrement soignée il publie
d'ailleurs en 1950 les fouilles
préhistoriques techniques et méthodes un
livre qui expose sa méthode décapage
horizontale minutieux pour dégager des
soldes habitat entier et pouvoir étudier
la disposition des vestiges en place à
l'opposé des techniques de bourrin de
l'époque 1964 est une année chargée pour
andré leur grand désormais professeur à
la sorbonne et publie une théorie
générale d'interprétation de l'art p
olitique dans les religions de la
préhistoire
c'est aussi en 64 qui publie son ouvrage
le plus reconnu le geste et la parole
une synthèse magistrale de ces travaux
théoriques et c'est toujours en 64 qui
commence la fouille du site
préhistorique de placement
cet apaisement que leroi gourhan à
l'opportunité de démontrer toute
l'excellence de sa méthode du décapage
horizontale grâce aux relevés
topographiques systématique il relève
les agencements des différentes cabane
la position des foyers et les activités
du quotidien des chasseurs paléolithique
pincement permet enfin une véritable et
naulleau préhistoriques qu'il appelait
de ses voeux en 69 il entre au collège
de france et donne pendant 13 ans à un
coût sur l'art paléolithique les malades
de parkinson il s'affaiblit assez vite
dans les années 70 il s'efface
progressivement de la fouille de
pincement qui continue sans lui et
qu'ils visitent souvent il prend sa
retraite universitaire en 82 et meurt
finalement à 74 ans en février 86 sa
volonté de renouveler les méthodes et de
croiser les approches une très
durablement marqué les sciences humaines
[Musique]
né à paris en 1928 michelle perrot vient
d'un milieu bourgeois elle étudie dans
une pension de catholiques mais son père
est particulièrement libérale et
souhaite que sa fille se cultive et soit
indépendante elle étudie l'histoire à la
sorbonne après guerre et lee deuxième
sexe de simone de beauvoir dès sa sortie
en 49 cette lecture l'inspirent beaucoup
et perrot propose à son professeur
ernest labrousse de faire son mémoire de
recherche sur ces mini sme mais la
brousse la dissuade en lui prédisant
qu'elle ne ferait pas carrière avec ça
et l'orientent vers l'histoire sociale
plus en vogue à l'université l'étude du
monde ouvrier marque donc le premier
temps de son travail perreault et y
apporte une vision particulière elle
s'attache notamment aux gestes et aux
discours et publie sa thèse les ouvriers
en grève donner une histoire à la classe
ouvrière est pour elle une manière de
les rejoindre et de lutter malgré ses
origines sociales ce travail participe
d'un courant très large et elle n'est
pas vraiment une pionnière dans ce
domaine
c'est le cas en revanche pour ses autres
objets d'étude car michel perron est en
parallèle l'une des premières
historienne à s'intéresser aux prisons
elle publie délinquance et système
pénitentiaire en france au 19e siècle en
1975 la même année que surveiller punir
de michel foucault mais michelle perrot
est aussi et surtout connu pour son
travail sur les femmes l'éclatement de
l'université de paris après 68 l'a
conduit à enseigner à l'université paris
7 à jussieu et c'est là qu'elle peut
organiser avec pauline schmitt et
familles de boeck en 73 le séminaire les
femmes ont-elles une histoire c'est tout
simplement le premier cours sur
l'histoire des femmes à l'université en
france dans les années qui suivent
d'autres cours secret à aix marseille ou
à toulouse et perrot explore d'autres
thématiques comme femmes et familles
femmes et travail ou encore histoire des
féminismes
contrairement à la prédiction de son
professeur c'est bien l'histoire des
femmes qui l'a fait connaître c'est
celle qui attire le plus d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes sans doute parce qu'elle
répond à une question plus largement
partagée et souvent existentielle perron
fait aussi toute sa place au concept de
genre lorsqu'il s'impose en france
depuis les états unis mais perraud ne
veut pas faire une histoire des femmes
qui soit uniquement celle de leur
domination
d'autant qu'elle reconnaît le travail de
françoise héritier par exemple pour
démêler versa
concrètement cela se traduit par l'étude
des vies individuels dont elle veut
dévoiler l'expérience sensible vide
femmes illustres comme george sand ou
d'inconnus comme lui si beau une
ouvrière de la soie elle dirige aussi
avec georges duby une histoire des
femmes en occident une somme de cinq
volumes publiés entre 90 et 91 on peut
en fait comprendre le travail de michel
perron comme la volonté de donner la
parole à celles et ceux qui en ont été
privés et trois sujets d'étude qui ont
été les siens ouvriers détenus et femmes
partagent un statut secondaire et ont
longtemps été gommée de l'histoire par
les grands événements son travail s'est
donc attaché à révéler les modalités de
leur exclusion à explorer comme elle le
dit le continent perdu des vies englouti
faire ça c'est bien sûr un acte militant
qui révèle l'exclusion qui existe
toujours et michelle perrot continue à
90 ans passés de donner des conférences
de s'exprimer dans la presse comme lors
du mouvement de mitu par exemple en
vulgarisant son travail à la radio en
enregistrant des versions audio de ses
livres elle a essayé de rendre
accessibles ses recherches au plus grand
nombre et c'est pour ça qu'on les aime
bah c'est la fin de notre petit marathon
ou de notre sprint plutôt des
intellectuels français alors on aurait
pu en choisir d'autres on en a
d'ailleurs évoqué certains auguste-comte
marcel mauss michel foucault ou encore
françoise héritier il fallait se limiter
à n'ont même pas ce que moi là après le
montage les gars
le cadre la contrainte c'est important
je vous cache pas que ça a d'ailleurs
été assez frustrant de couper pas mal
d'éléments pour tenir le format mais
même si on n'a fait qu'effleurer leurs
idées ben j'espère sera pu donner envie
à certains certaine d'aller creuser un
peu je vous rappelle que si vous voulez
on peut faire une lecture de quelques
passages de leurs oeuvres dans un live
instagram et qu'on pourra échanger sur
les textes les plus abordables pour
commencer bien entendu on pourra faire
des critiques également et sinon bah
tous les ouvrages sur le thème barre
d'infos merci à hainaut d'eau pour avoir
sponsorisé l'épisode je vous rappelle
que le jeu hier jtekt paris est
disponible en ce moment sur steam si
vous voulez repeindre le collège de
france agrandir les universités mettre
un totem un amérindien à la place de la
colonne vendôme est lassé de jeu qu'il
vous faut à la prochaine
lula veut
[Musique]